Hey hydro nice to meet you sure yeah
well I think everyone just tried say you
know try to do it a little bit yeah
I wish I was wearing what you were
wearing there's no cards or is that part
of the outfit actually a magnet and a
wooden just a wooden square so it's part
of the outfit yeah gotcha yeah it's me
guys so we should make our own spy super
team because we're all matching today
yeah yeah right this is what's up
Kingsman three sub like a post James
Bond age but yeah King is minutes it's
own thing now and people are really
excited about this second film were you
guys excited to jump on board this I was
very excited um I came into the process
a little early and was developing the
role of agent whiskey with Matthew bond
through a pretty arduous process of
auditioning for the part really and then
get to the finish line and at that point
how he's involved Julianne Moore Jeff
Bridges
Channing Tatum so it was like this
embarrassment of riches yeah and then I
got nervous and then you got nervous
well what happened went out the John
stepped on it said to get more nervous
or what well I think that that's just a
paralysis of like icon it it's like when
you go icon and you are iconic to me
I wouldn't have been able to do it sorry
oh good I'd be like and I think yeah
excuse me three I'm thinking we should
see you like finally get into action
right I mean this is gonna happen this
is the thing you're playing coy but it's
gonna happen are you like just chopping
in the bits I like to do like lassos and
whips and shoot guns know that burn I'm
gonna do nice what you guys doing what
was the most fun thing to do like it
looks like you're an expert at that whip
man for me the most fun would be the
whip yeah she can understand as Catwoman
once you start cracking that thing it's
very addictive and it's real fun to do
to crack that whip yeah most fun I had
was watching him roped I stuck to it
didn't have the use of his hands and you
had to write okay cool
yeah it's a scene that is not in the
movies nothing nice I mean the thing was
we going it wasn't going well it seems
like it sounds like the way yours thing
it's the thing that people need to see
they're gonna see the DVD I'm sure
Matthew is going to bring this comedy to
the screen every statesman has like a
you know a drink based name during this
code name what would my drink based code
name be just from knowing move like
three minutes dirty martini
Oh dirty Marc thank you thank you but it
wasn't like Aperol spritz or something
those good dirty martinis great and
we're gonna end on that guys I'm gonna
go I'm gonna get a training for human
for cuz I'm not gonna be the next one
okay agent